on va laisser les gens arriver
takatak ça fait 30 secondes
[Musique]
on va y aller de façon doucement mais
sûrement
mesdames messieurs bienvenue planète
raft saison 2 c'est parti nouveau projet
des nouvelles têtes des moins nouvelles
têtes aujourd'hui je suis accompagné du
poste Alex
commence à
tout va bien tout va bien ici au Plaza
Alex qui a eu un été chargé vu qu'il a
recruté deux roues qui connus dans la
scouting dans le scooting game FR avec
Mathias Equestre et Thomas et qui est
comment ça va les gars bonne première à
vous
merci
et ça va très très bien on est prêt pour
parler prospects aujourd'hui ça va bien
les plus réactifs à vouloir participer
c'est de très bonne augure pour cette
saison on est prêt on va faire un petit
point quand même parce qu'il y a des on
va un petit peu changer le concept on va
vraiment se focaliser sur la draft 2023
donc l'idée ce serait de parler d'un
maximum de prospects que vous allez
retrouver qui vont être dans les big
board et autres moves draft en fin
d'année
là pour l'instant il y a une première
partie dans l'année dernière ça a été
les boschistes les Wall Street c'est
quoi c'est les joueurs sur lesquels on a
au fond de l'espoir en début de saison
là il y avait eu très peu de matchs des
matchs sans enjeux des matchs amicaux
donc là c'est on a un peu dans dans
vraiment de l'hyperprojection j'ai envie
de dire et après tous les gens tous les
intervenants qui ont qui ont revu ces
gars reviendront et nous donnerons un
petit peu on fera là un point plus
précis dans une deuxième partie de ces
dons donc un peu plus tard dans l'année
donc voilà un peu comment on va
s'organiser cette année les planètes
draft et puis en fin de saison après la
loterie on fera sans doute comme l'année
dernière avec l'équipe rareté avec les
équipes concernées donc coucou au fin de
Uta Charlotte tout ça qui vont être
sûrement parmi nous on prend déjà date
je vous rappelle aussi que planète rap
c'est interactif vous avez le chat bien
évidemment dans le chat on attend de
vous que vous soyez courtois et poli
bien évidemment que aussi on se respecte
c'est le but on fera aussi attention
parce que l'année dernière on était pas
mal envoyé aussi par les boots russes
donc si jamais si jamais on hésitez pas
à signaler et on essaiera de d'enlever
ça
donc voilà pour la présentation un petit
peu de cette année de comment ça va se
dérouler
aujourd'hui watchlist pour deux pour des
conflits assez importantes à savoir la
quantité Atlantique tn et Big Time avec
Matthias et la SIC avec Thomas on va
commencer avec Matthias
présente-nous un petit peu
ces deux confs que sont la quantité et
la Bitcoin
bon alors déjà la Big tn ce qui est la
plus grosse des deux on va dire
c'est une conf qui regroupe déjà les
facs de Michigan avec Michigan et
Michigan State
on a d'autres d'autres
programmes avec il est noir
ou encore où est-ce qu'on seen qu'on
avait vu l'année dernière avec Johnny
Davis
des équipes de bons niveaux et qui
souvent ont des
objectifs assez élevés concernant la
mars madness
cette année on est sur sur des équipes
qui ont peut-être une moins bonne
mais moins bonne chance d'aller loin en
marche Madness en tout cas
mais c'est souvent des équipes qui qui
vont qui vont qui vont qui vont être
performantes
et pour ce qui est de l'Atlantique tn
alors là c'est plus
c'est moins au niveau mais c'est quand
même des bonnes équipes on a des équipes
comme Davidson la fac de Steph curry si
je me trompe pas
ou encore des femmes comme comme viciu
qui a régulièrement des prospects NBA
ces dernières années
oui d'autres fois comme Richmond
Island voilà
tu nous as sorti quelques joueurs boulot
qui pour toi ont une chance dans la
discussion en tout cas au moins en juin
prochain je te laisse commencer par
celui de ton choix
bah alors je vais commencer par
les petits fresh man
évidemment ce qu'on attend le plus
je vais commencer avec
moi quelle Clark le plus beau projet de
capillaire c'est vrai c'est vrai
dans c'est un mec qui vient de
Californie c'est un combo Guard d'un
mètre 80 11 traitée
90 kg
que autant
il est jeune mais il est déjà bien
développé physiquement
donc combo Guard qui peut quitter à fac
demande donc très connu à la fac pardon
ou très connu et qui a vu sa saison
écourtée à cause d'une blessure au
croisé alors c'était pas une rupture
c'était moins grave qu'une rupture mais
c'était quand même les croisés et donc
ça saison a été un peu gâchée
mais pour autant il a quand même eu des
grosses offres
et apparemment vu ce que j'ai vu à
récupérer très très vite et donc ce qui
soulignait apparemment une très bonne
mentalité pour lui une très bonne étude
de travail donc ça c'est quand même
positif
donc pour parler du joueur c'est un
point de gare qui est très à l'aise Ball
en main avec un bundle présence de la
passe et qui est aussi un potentiel de
scorer 3 niveaux avec une mécanique de
shop ultra rapide
et qui a des beaux petits flashs en
poule donc déjà
peut-être qu'il faut développer un peu
le scorer trois niveaux qu'est-ce que tu
entends par là
ou soit bien clair pour tout le monde au
niveau alors déjà il peut shooter de
loin donc il a un shoot extérieur déjà
un shoot à 3 points ce qui est quand
même la base pour un la base maintenant
à l'heure actuelle pour un pour un
meneur pour un jour extérieur très
doué aussi pour attaquer attaquer
attaquer l'arceau et aussi un peu moins
mais un vrai jeu à distance
donc voilà ce qu'on appelle trois
niveaux
donc en fait c'est un joueur assez cool
avoir joué très flashy
qui va qui va bien attirer les yeux je
pense à edinoy dans une équipe qui en
plus à pas grand monde à ce poste là
cette année et qui va avoir en plus un
jeu complètement différent cette année
puisque koffic burn le joueur auquel
tout passait l'année dernière et parti
donc je pense que ce cas là va avoir pas
mal de ballon en main cette année
c'était le groupe pivot qui prenait
énormément de place
un format que Nico apprécierait sur le
papier en tout cas
tu nous as parlé donc de son jeu
offensif qu'est-ce que défensivement il
a montré ce garçon High School
défensivement c'est un petit peu la
question
toujours dur de juger surtout que c'est
pas en tout cas c'est pas là qu'on
l'attend donc on va mieux le juger
ensiller mais bon là ce qu'on attend de
lui ce qu'on va attendre de lui en NCIS
ça défense justement comme tu dis et
aussi son playmaking où on va l'attendre
on sait que c'est un bon shooter on
aimerait bien le voir plus au playmaking
et après au niveau quelque chose qui
m'est très cher c'est au niveau
comportement attitude comment il se
comment il est sur un terrain qu'est-ce
que c'est quelqu'un de vocal est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un de plus réservé est-ce
que c'est quelqu'un dans les temps
mortier ou qui est un peu plus dans son
monde il commence sur un terrain de
basket
sur Internet basket il est plutôt moi je
vois une belle petite âme de leader en
tout cas si général sur le terrain
hésite pas à prendre des choses quand il
faut et concernant son étude de travail
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
apparemment il est très bienvenu de sa
blessure donc j'ai pas vraiment doute là
dessus ça mentalité en tout cas je pense
que il
aurait peut-être sur les épaules et puis
sur le terrain il le démontre il le
démontre bien
quand je parlais de projet capillaire
pour vous faire une idée arrêtez moi si
je me trompe mais on est quand même très
proche de JD Davidson le voir qui a été
drafté par Boston on a un petit peu dans
ces Zola si vous connaissez pas aller
voir c'est assez magnifique on espère
pour lui forcément un destin haute que
JDV Davidson qui était annoncé très haut
en début d'année dernière et qui s'est
retrouvé drafté en 56e position 55e par
Boston donc on espère que ce sera pas le
cas pour lui est-ce que tu as fini avec
lui et où on passe à un autre un autre
freshman Mathias
ouais on va pouvoir passer à jet Award
petit chouchou de mon côté
donc jet Awards
de mettre 3 98 kg
qui vient de Miami
fist du coach de Michigan la salle dans
laquelle il va jouer donc on peut
évidemment soupçonné qu'il aura des du
temps de jeu cette année donc en High
School il joue à l'IMG Academy avec
d'autres grosses recrues 5 étoiles comme
dernièrement il a été le MVP du iderson
classique voilà ça anecdotique mais bon
je voulais quand même le noter donc ce
qui est intéressant chez lui c'est que
c'est un joueur
vraiment projetable en NBA car déjà il a
la taille pour son poste taille parfaite
pour jouer 3 mais c'est un élu aussi qui
s'est posé le ballon qui s'est posé le
ballon qui s'est shooté et qui s'est
défendre
donc ce qu'on demande souvent NBA
maintenant
athlétique c'est pas c'est pas le joueur
le plus athlétique mais c'est pas c'est
pas non plus catastrophique son physique
bah il est presque NBA déjà
et son shoot c'est je pense ça plus
belle arme pour l'instant il a de
mécanique vraiment très belle avec un
beau jumper qui part très vite
et surtout en cas de shoot en sortie
d'écran en pull up c'est pas encore ça
mais c'est un axe de progression pour
lui en tout cas
pas dans un profil un petit peu de
friendy on sait que les profits c'est
important pour les draft est-ce que son
papier ça ressemble pas à ça
trois points et puis surtout un bon
défenseur qui sera très versatile qui
pourra défendre plusieurs postes
donc c'est sûr que c'est facile de le
projeter dans un dans un dans un profil
de Trump aussi qui peut être un peu plus
que ça parce que honnêtement c'est un
élève qui s'est vraiment posé le ballon
et qui a un handball vraiment
intéressant donc je sais pas s'il aura
le ballon à main en tout cas avec
Michigan mais ce sera ce sera
intéressant de d'observer ça en tout cas
après Alex ouais à Michigan il y a eu
quand même pas mal de changements cette
année non mais c'était ma question tu
vois que je rebondisse au fur et à
mesure ouais ouais bien sûr parce que
non mais parce que Clark par exemple
je suis plutôt réservé même si j'ai je
connais moins que Mathias mais pour le
coup de ce que j'ai vu à cette taille là
alors déjà pardon parenthèse mais
pourquoi des gens qui jouent au basket
et qui veulent être professionnels ont
cette coupe de cheveux c'est pas
pratique
non mais c'est pas tu vois c'est pas
pratique du tout je veux dire les
extrêmes que d'Alison non c'est vrai
mais je veux dire on n'a jamais vu le
meilleur sportif de quelconque sport du
monde avoir une coupe de cheveux comme
ça donc c'est pas un hasard un moment
donné c'est à dire que coupez-vous les
cheveux bref c'est une parenthèse
Skype là que j'y crois moyen parce qu'il
est trop petit pour moi sauf si il fait
une saison extraordinaire au shoot mais
falloir qu'il reste enfin pense pas que
dès son année freshman ça va être
compliqué quoi
mais c'est un beau joueur effectivement
et ouais Michigan ils ont bah ils ont
gardé interditkinson quand même
et en fait c'est hyper bien pour jet
Howard qui s'est gardé Hunter Dickinson
parce que
mine de rien ça donne un point d'appui à
l'intérieur il est hyper fort au poste
Hunter Dickinson pour ceux qui
connaissent pas ça en 5 un peu à
l'ancienne mais qui se modernise parce
qu'il s'écarte et il a un vrai un vrai
jeu au poste bas il sait faire des
passes il va forcément avoir des shoots
ouverts grâce à Hunter Dickinson ça
c'est cool et en plus il
plombe pas le spaceing non plus tu vois
si jamais je sais pas
à un contrat à jouer en fin de
possession ou quoi que ce soit le
Dickinson est dangereux à trois points
donc c'est pas c'est plutôt positif pour
tout pour l'équipe de Michigan en en
général mais donc pour jet Howard en
particulier l'année dernière c'est un
peu compliqué à Michigan au niveau du
spaceing là on a des gars le meneur de
Princeton qui arrive je le connais pas
beaucoup mais
c'est pas un grand distributeur mais par
contre c'est un gars qui perd pas
beaucoup de ballon et qui joue bien
tu vois on a on a Joey Baker qui arrive
pareil c'est un gars qui va la mettre
des mandats et
qui va protéger les jeunes et puis et
puis il y a Youssef Hyat
qui qui va être en concurrence avec GTA
et qu'on a vu pour ceux qui lisent
envergure en espoir l'année dernière en
bet liée était à Limoges et c'est un
Libanais
et c'est vraiment un très bon joueur
c'est frais il était 12e de notre Top 25
espoir l'année dernière et il est mature
tu vois je pense que en fait c'est une
équipe de gars tu vois le meneur c'est
un quatrième année dit kinson c'est un
troisième année du safrayat il est déjà
mature physiquement c'est une équipe qui
va pas se laisser taper dessus et du
coup c'est bien mais par contre il va
falloir que Ward il s'y mettre je sais
pas
j'ai beaucoup vu shooter dans ce que
j'ai vu je n'ai pas beaucoup vu à aller
au mastic
et cela s'il va pas ça va se voir direct
parce que autour de lui il y a que des
gars qui mettent des néons mais sinon je
suis d'accord c'est hyper facile à
projeter
un profil assez rare dans cette draft en
fait d'avoir déjà ce shoot là bien bien
propre etc et
je dis pas qui va se faire drafter
l'autrip parce que tu vois si il est
spécialiste du tir et qui montre pas
énormément de choses mais par contre tu
prends pas beaucoup de risques
pour ceux qui entrons le pareil jet
Award est-ce que tu avais fini Mathias
avec lui est-ce que justement ce que
disait Alex par rapport peut-être au
manque de comment on peut dire de dureté
non c'est pas ça vraiment non je dis pas
qu'il en manquait je dis que s'il en
manque ça va se voir ok ça marche c'est
la nuit
il va avoir des responsabilités
défensives parce que Dickinson c'est pas
le meilleur défenseur déjà
et puis au tour il y a pas de gros gros
défenseur donc je pense qu'il aura des
sacrés responsabilités défensives donc
on va le voir
avec le papa qu'il a c'est quand même
normalement le côté rigueur c'est un peu
il a fait sa gueule donc on peut espérer
que le garçon est récupéré un petit peu
ça du paternel il y a son frère aussi
ouais il y a son frère aussi
c'est ça
est-ce que tu as d'autres choses à
rajouter sur jetower
non je pense pas non on va pouvoir on va
du coup
allez c'est parti
du coup monsieur daronne Holmes que vous
verrez je pense beaucoup dans les moques
draft cette année
je l'ai vu beaucoup apprécié en tout cas
aux États-Unis ce que je les vois même
l'année dernière je l'ai vu pas mal de
fois tourné dans des MOOC
c'est un poste 5
un peu undersize je te coupe 2 secondes
déjà on note le la spécialité américaine
de mettre la majuscule au milieu du
prénom ça c'est très important
2 mètres 0,8 pour un pivot
100 kg alors il paraît un peu frêle
comme ça
mais il est vraiment compact et
il va pas se faire enfoncer au poste
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser à
première vue en tout cas
donc daronne qui va jouer à Dayton je
l'ai pas dit donc Dayton qui aussi a
envoyé pas mal de joueurs en
[Musique]
NBA avec hobby je crois
récemment le dernier
donc
un pivot grande envergure très long j'ai
lignes qui étaient au lycée dans la dans
le lycée de AZ Compass recrut 4 étoiles
dont personne ne parlait beaucoup à
l'époque et puis en fait il arrivait
dans une équipe de Dayton qui a décidé
de faire jouer tous ses flashman et
donner beaucoup de minutes à ses French
man
après
il a pu se montrer et
attirer et attirer les observateurs
donc c'est un pivot très mobile qui
court très bien
qui fait des allers-retours sur le
terrain assez incroyable pour sa taille
donc déjà le jeu rapide c'est pas du
tout un problème pour lui
pareil en défense très mobile il va
pouvoir switcher très facilement
ce qu'on attend de plus en plus on NBA
pas peur de défendre loin du panier
qui défend très bien en drop aussi
et puis aussi évidemment
capacité de
protection d'arceau il a une grosse
moyenne au bloc j'ai pas le chiffre sous
les yeux mais en pourcentage l'année
dernière sur la zone regardez le
pourcentage donc c'est très très correct
gros bloqueur gros bloqueur et en plus
il y en a beaucoup qui sont pris assez
loin de l'arceau donc sur des pull-up
adverses
et offensivement c'est un joueur qui en
tout cas niveau des stats et élite à la
finition parce qu'il finit à 80%
sur plus de 200 tentatives donc c'est
assez exceptionnel
très bon dans le dunker spot très bon
cutter qui est aussi un petit peu de
foot work pour finir donc donc voilà on
a un joueur qui est très bon en tout cas
en défense et qui va très bien finir les
actions de l'autre côté du terrain
est-ce que c'est une loft target
oui oui clairement on est vraiment sur
ça beaucoup pas vu assez joué pendant ce
temps je te demande mais c'est un peu le
profil qu'on avait pour faire une
détente donc pour faire une comparaison
de toute façon qui va être désastreuse
est-ce que c'est il y a pas un petit
côté Robert Williams là dedans un petit
peu dans la façon de jouer avec
athlétique mobile conter et je mets des
points près du cercle parce qu'on n'est
pas alors il est il est pas aussi stock
que Robert Williams
mais dans le rôle le web pivot puis
wondersize qui va pouvoir défendre très
bien loin du panier et tout c'est vrai
que Robert Williams c'est pas une
comparaison horrible
[Musique]
il y a un mongole à mongolien
Mike il l'appelle parce que il a un nom
un pronom
et qui a un prospect un vrai prospect
mongolienne Mike c'est peut-être le
meilleur prospect de ses équipes un
grand gourde
ouais
ils ont enfin landais
comment il s'appelle déjà
Mustapha Amzil
et ils ont et c'est que des joueurs qui
sont un peu
pour un esprit de voilà passer là-bas un
peu basket FIBA tu vois et
du coup c'est assez excitant et et en
général et pour daronne Holmes qui ne
devrait avoir que des shoots faciles à
mettre donc si donc il faut qu'il ait
une efficacité s'il veut se faire
drafter il faut qu'il ait une efficacité
de port
et peut-être soit qui bloque encore un
peu plus de tir
soit qui prennent un peu plus de rebonds
Mathias disait il est un peu plus loin
mais c'est parce que il a ce rôle là
aussi de switcher un peu plus qu'un big
normal tu vois mais
c'est très rare en fait de drafter des
bigs j'ai regardé les sur
du siège un fou avec bartorvik là j'ai
regardé les depuis 2008 les gars qui
sont dans les midmate genre et qui se
font drafter les pivots
et qui sont pas fraîchement il faut
qu'ils aient soit un pourcentage de
blocs hyper élevé soit qui soit
ultra dominant
et donc il va falloir qu'il fasse un des
deux de toute façon il faut qu'il soit
un bon finisseur et et les 58% c'est
France c'est pas possible c'est 70
minimum situation drafté alors le shoot
c'est clairement un axe de progression
pour lui c'est vrai que son pourcentage
dans ses francs est horrible mais
pendant la saison je l'ai vu prendre pas
mal de midrange et ses cartes pas de
plus en plus donc je pense je pense
qu'il a progresser en tout cas son
pourcentage dans ses francs
[Musique]
relativement propre parce qu'on a aussi
des fois des mécaniques assez baroque
chez les pivots à cet âge-là
est-ce que tu as quelque chose vous avez
quelque chose à rajouter sur l'ami
daronne 2
on peut passer au suivant ah on va
passer au sujet qui fait des bas
on va parler
quelqu'un qui arrive dans la conférence
si quelqu'un sait mettez dans les
commentaires
n'hésitez pas
alors Shannon junior pourquoi c'est un
prospect c'est toujours un prospect NBA
pour toi Mathias dis-nous tout ça fait
maintenant 3 ans qu'on en parle je crois
mais je ne désespère pas je ne désespère
pas
alors il était à Texas text depuis 3 ans
il a transféré cet été à Illinois
pour jouer justement à côté de Skype
park on a vu tout à l'heure donc pose
deux trois d'un mètre 98
qui a donc fait ces années à Texas steak
dans une équipe qui prône la défense
ce qui est d'ailleurs pas une de ces
enfin qui est d'ailleurs une de ses
qualités que j'aime beaucoup chez lui
donc gros défenseur sur l'homme qui peut
vraiment être une teigne en tout cas
et en attaque un shoot donc on a déjà un
peu le friendy pour moi
en tout cas alors son shoot est pas au
pourcentage
peut paraître fiable mais il en a pris
beaucoup en pull up et en tout cas en 4e
shoot je pense qu'il sera qui sera
fiable en suivant
ensuite
c'est un joueur qui finit très très bien
les actions
qui va lâcher des tomates très
facilement
puis
moi ce que j'aime surtout chez lui c'est
son jeu au ball mais il joue pas assez
en fait
c'est un joueur très intelligent qui
code bien et qui vraiment a tout à
gagner à jouer plus au bol sauf que lui
ne se voit pas comme ça en fait
lui il se voit comme un joueur porteur
sauf qu'il a pas le handle pour ça
et
je pense que dans un Star qui va le
faire comprendre qu'il est pas dans
cette optique là je pense que il pourra
être très très bon et pour ça que en NBA
je pense qu'il peut qui peut avoir sa
place
alex je te mets sur tes hanches est-ce
que tu es aussi optimiste que Mathias
non non moi je l'ai barré de ma liste
depuis longtemps mais
c'est pas dire que j'ai raison
parce qu'en fait il progresse pas pour
moi il progresse un peu au tir un petit
peu aussi et heureusement
mais il a toujours pas au volume
et puis plus les années passent plus ils
perdent de ballons quoi tu sais c'est un
joueur au moins une ou deux fois par
match je suis dit mais qu'est-ce qu'il
fait
mais vraiment
je peux pas donc j'ai barré mais mais
pour le coup
un peu bien esthétique ces dernières
années je déteste et que ça steak plus
profond de mon cœur
déteste la façon dont
qui oriente ligne de fond et provoque
des passages en force en profitant des
règles NCA en gros si schématise
et je vous le rebond offensif
et
donc là il va avoir le déjà le loisir de
montrer qui peut être un vrai défenseur
gros défenseur sur l'homme puisqu'il a
il en a les qualités physiques
et puis bon ben voilà comme dit Mathias
il accepte son rôle
et qui rendent s'étire il va falloir
qu'il en rende beaucoup à haut volume et
qui fasse pas beaucoup d'erreurs parce
qu'il est quatrième année donc en fait
rien lui passer tu vois avec Baji
premier tour mais parce qu'il fait une
saison extraordinaire
donc il a une chance d'être drafté parce
qu'il a des qualités physiques mais bon
j'y crois pas trop mais j'attends de
voir si le contexte stylinois change le
joueur ce qui est possible aussi
il s'était présenté excuse-moi
sa saison sofamor et cetera finalement
alors que honnêtement moi je le voyais
bien rester et puis là cette saison la
saison dernière il a été embêté par les
blessures il a eu un gros gros début de
saison et puis il a une blessure qui l'a
complètement stoppé derrière il a repris
deux trois matchs il a eu encore un
problème d'éligibilité ou je sais plus
trop ce qui s'est passé et en fait sa
saison a été coupée sans arrêt il a pas
trouvé son rythme
et donc du coup je pense que elle est
pas vraiment à retenir cette saison là
après moi je partage ton avis sur le
problème du rôle c'est à dire que on a
l'impression d'avoir qui va un rôle qui
ne peut pas avoir en fait donc c'est
vrai que si par bonheur pour lui il
accepte un rôle qui est différent et
nouveau peut-être que il peut aussi
regagner des coeurs de certains scouts
NBA parce que effectivement après les
outils ils sont quand même les avoir au
moins niveau athlétique au moins au
niveau défensif et après est-ce que je
parierai sur ça je pense pas non plus
donc ouais il est noir on a déjà parlé
sur le contexte avec Skype calacre ça va
être un petit peu normand normalement le
duo qui va les les porter c'est un peu
le projet
Alex
oui après ils ont une ils ont Mathieu
Mayer
offensivement c'est bien aussi mais tu
m'as l'air qui vient de bailar qui va
porter du tir
ouais non moi j'aime bien
absolument et pour le coup qui lui est
je l'ai vu dans la main qui espionne
mais après leur pivot par contre il est
c'est pas kofficher donc ça va pas être
le même point de fixation on va surtout
lui demander de faire le sale boulot
mais oui il aura des ballons
on va du côté de Richmond Mathias
allez
allez Tyler Burton parle-nous de Tyler
Burton pareil un joueur qui arrive en
essayant je crois
ouais c'est ça
alors Tyler Burton donc il joue à
Richmond
Richmond qui peut compétitive
généralement dans la conférence
atlanticaine et qui va cette année être
la première option offensive de son
équipe il était à moins
un peu moins l'année dernière mais un
petit peu quand même mais cette année il
y a le meneur star de l'équipe Jacob
Giler qui est parti
et du coup il va avoir énormément de
responsabilités et je pense que il va
attirer beaucoup plus les yeux
donc c'est un joueur post 3 qui pourra
jouer qui est plus un 4 NBA pour moi
dans un Small Ball qui a un bon shoot un
très beau shoot à trois points qui est
très solide physiquement pas le meilleur
athlète mais physiquement il est très
bien bâti
et qui marque de plein de manières en
fait en NBA je pense pas qu'il pourra
marquer de plein de manières parce qu'il
se crée pas son shoot mais ce sera un
joueur qui sera un vrai joueur de fin de
chaîne et qui défendra bien sur des sur
des 4 sur des trois je pense que c'est
un peu plus compliqué parce que c'est
pas le genre le plus mobile en tout cas
mais sur des petits quatre ou des 4 je
pense qu'il va pouvoir défendre donc un
joueur qui shoot à trois points à 36%
mais c'est un bien meilleur shooter que
ça
fin décembre il est à 45% à 3 points
avant de s'écrouler un petit peu au fil
de la saison mais en tout cas c'est un
très très bon shooter qui attaque très
bien les clausout qui est très bon of
bol aussi pas besoin du ballon pour
exister
qui code bien et qui crossent même des
fois j'ai vu des clips de lui oui qui
croient ses adversaires un peu de
manière assez incroyable
et donc donc voilà un profil un petit
peu sur quoi qui pourra être drafté dans
un second tour
j'ai regardé un petit peu le profil et
les stats quelque chose qui m'a attiré
c'est son nom de rebonds qu'il a c'est
que c'est un énorme redeur est-ce que
c'était contextuel c'était dans le
contexte de Richmond où il y avait pas
un pivot exprès pour ça ou comment ça
s'explique une vraie science du robot
cette année va y en avoir un parce
qu'ils ont ils ont transféré
un pivot assez grand mais où il a aussi
une science du rebond qui est assez
intéressante c'est un joueur aussi qui
est très long donc ça l'aide beaucoup
pour pour prendre des
Alex au niveau du contexte de Richmond
le contexte je peux
en fait j'ai pas l'impression que ça va
ni l'aider ni le desservir il va avoir
plus de tir il va pas forcément être
plus efficace mais c'est pas sur ça
qu'on va le juger il aura pas le même
rôle que ce que ce qui pourrait avoir en
pro après en fait il avait déclaré déjà
l'année dernière
avant de retirer son nom et en fait je
pense que
à son âge s'il avait dû être drafté il
aurait été drafté et que ça m'a l'air
compliqué de passer un tel palier cette
année
d'un coup il va être drafté l'année
prochaine
[Musique]
donc à moins qu'il devienne un shooter
différent en fait c'est un bon shooter
et je trouve qu'il peut tu vois faudrait
qu'il ait une variété un peu folle qui
se découvre
un shooter après mouvement incroyable
que
et peut-être que pour le coup cette
option le fait d'être option numéro 1 ça
peut changer ça tu vois qui qui sont
coach soit créatif et mettre en place
des systèmes où on va le faire courir et
c'est lui qui va ouvrir des espaces etc
mais sinon
c'est un bon défenseur mais c'est pas
non plus le défenseur de l'année en NBA
moi je pense que c'est plus un joueur
qui est fait pour l'Europe que pour la
NBA je pense que c'est un très bon
joueur de
betclicalité tu vois je pense ça peut
être un bon joueur
parce qu'après même sur les qualités
athlétiques il est il est solide mais il
est pas hyper haut hyper vite en fait en
tout cas moi
quand même
mais physiquement il est ultra solide il
a des épaules passionnantes
mais je suis un peu et je pense que je
sais pas au shoot
pour moi les règles les très bonseurs
ils ont plus de 85 % lancer France un
peu cette billet et lui il a jamais
progressé
il y a un gros volume aussi
par contre effectivement
on passe au dernier teliste Mathias on
va du côté de vcu
Jason notre équipe de l'Atlantique
tennis
Jane dans les traces de bonnes ouais et
devine Williams peut-être aussi donc
pour ça
du coup un mètre 93
86 kg post 1 2 qui était à la facchool
Dream City Christian School à côté de
shadownsharp et Arthur kaluma mais une
recrue notée deux étoiles donc vraiment
pas comment l'attendait
et donc il arrive à vicioux dans une
équipe compétitive qui visait la danse
Manesse
et qui réputé pour être axé sur la
défense en tout cas et il est arrivé
première année et il a pris 30 minutes
de moyenne
en fabriquant parfaitement dans le dans
le système défensif de son équipe parce
que c'est un excellent défenseur encore
une fois très très fort sur l'homme très
très mobile très vif
vraiment il peut éteindre son son fils
son visage alors il a un petit peu plus
tête en l'air mais sur l'homme il est
très très fort et offensivement on est
plus dans le wifi
mais il y a des très on peut s'attendre
à de très belles choses il était la
troisième ou quatrième option offensive
de son équipe derrière elle se Baldwin
ou wins Williams qui maintenant est
parti je pense qu'il aura beaucoup plus
de responsabilités cette année et on va
beaucoup plus le voir on l'a déjà vu
scré son shoot et c'est là vraiment le
potentiel que je vois chez lui c'est un
bon shooter qui peut se créer son shoot
avec des beaux flashs en pull-up et un
très bon number donc
il y a un vrai joueur alors il a un
petit peu vieux déjà pour son pour sa
saison sauf aux morts
à 21 ans bientôt je crois il aura 22 ans
l'année prochaine je crois
je crois que c'est en 2001
ça fait 2 ans que vicioux sort des
joueurs à la draft je me dis que ça peut
être le troisième pire est-ce que pour
voir comme ça combo
point de garde shooting garde le 1,8 à 6
par match se fait pas un peu peur
voilà si clairement c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'on va plus le voir au
playmaking cette année en tout cas je
l'attends beaucoup là-dessus j'aimerais
bien qu'il aille chercher au moins 2,5
ou 3 à 6 par match parce que sinon
j'aurais du mal à lui trouver un rôle
vraiment NBA si il a pas un peu plus de
playmaking
Alex dans la projection de vicioux
qu'est-ce que ça peut donner cette année
une bonne équipe ils ont perdu vins
Williams mais moi j'adore ice Baldwin
c'est
une de mes une de mes recherches l'année
dernière qui ressortait quand je faisais
des articles sur mes petits stats
avancés il y a un peu petit mais il est
il a le caractéristique des gens petits
qui réussissent c'est à dire qu'il est
épais quoi
et en plus il fait quand même 6-3 je
crois mais 90
et donc je l'aime beaucoup c'est le
meneur et mais j'aime bien la welcard de
Mathias j'aime bien cette idée de
joueurs qui progresse sur le tard qui
peut se créer son tir et il aura des
opportunités cette année à vicieux
j'aime bien la welcard et ça peut tout à
fait Fley out et rien faire du tout
parce que offensivement tu vois il y a
beaucoup de ballons perdus j'espère
qu'il y en aura moins c'était le gros
défaut de WC l'année dernière mais déjà
il y a des belles bases tu vois il sait
shooter il sait défendre c'est bien
et puis après le problème c'est qu'il
est trop petit pour être un vrai free
Andy
allèle après on sait maintenant que ça
se fait pour les arrières mais c'est
plutôt des arrières Marcus martien
mais bon si si
d'un coup il explose et qui met des
pull-up et qu'il est fou tu vois il en
est capable
[Musique]
c'est toujours des profils un peu
intrigants qui peuvent se drafter à 6k
93 dans des mecs qui se créent leur tir
c'est pas c'est c'est pas si courant
donc Mathias c'était un peu ta Walker
parmi ceux que tu as présenté en gros
grosso modo le gars qui peut pop cette
année si
alignement des planètes j'ai envie de
dire et puis si on prend soin ici
François des du ballon on va finir avec
la quantité et la bitaine avec Alex qui
va nous parler de Chris Murray un petit
peu avec
j'ai mis comme titre destin décalé bien
sûr en rapport avec son frère
tu avais écrit un article Alex ou
justement tu parlais de la jubilé un
petit peu dans l'espoir où il y avait un
cas qui avait été étudié c'était assez
intéressant cette histoire
c'est un truc qui est peu étudié parce
que évidemment des jumeaux monozygotes
il y en a sportif de haut niveau il y en
a pas énormément
simplement il y en a un qui a eu du
temps de jeu plutôt que l'autre et pour
des raisons qui sans doute expliquent
leurs différences de niveau actuellement
j'ai quand même pour vous étudier des
choses
qui gagnerait sur son année freshman
donc l'année précédant pas l'année
dernière mais sa première année je bois
18 minutes par match
et quand on mettait ces stats sur sur 40
minutes il était à 11 rebonds deux
styles trois blocs 59% en trou shooting
Chris l'année dernière
18 minutes par match 19
dire et sur 40 minutes 10 rebond de
styles de blocs 58% entre shooting
pourcentage autrement dit la même chose
avec une meilleure adresse à trois
points moins bonne adresse au lancer
franc
cette année
ils ont perdu
boanan
le
leur meneur arrière là Iowa
mais ils ont les frères mcaferry qui
apporte du
spaceing
et je pense que Chris me Ray il aura peu
ou proulé même opportunités qui
gagneraient avec l'année dernière
donc si il fait la même saison je vois
pas pourquoi alors il va pas être
racheté numéro 4
je vois pas pourquoi il serait pas de
rareté au moins en fin de premier tour
certes il aura un an de plus donc c'est
toujours moins bien mais fin de premier
début de seconde allez
il a de la taille il est déjà à droite
il est déjà 39% à 3 points sur cette
tentative par 40 minutes c'est un bon
shooter il faut qu'il faut qu'il règle
ce truc au lancer mais franchement
c'est un super joueur alors voilà ce qui
explique les différences entre les
jumeaux de performance entre les jumeaux
monozygotes c'est simplement les les
tests de personnalité donc c'est lié à
l'éducation un truc comme ça parce que
là ils sont dans le même contexte en
plus les jumeaux pour le quiz qui n'ont
pas de différence de développement ils
ont les mêmes entraînements
mais ce qui explique la différence dans
les études qui ont été faites pendant
une grande étude qui a été faite c'est
il y a le jumeau qui performait le moins
bien
était celui qui réagissait le moins bien
au test de personnalité sur la colère la
gestion de la colère ce genre de choses
et c'était genre il y en avait un qui
était médaillé olympique et l'autre qui
était même pas en finale
et donc peut-être que Chris Murray et le
jumeau colérique
mais s'il n'est pas
moi je pense que ça peut marcher donc
c'est ma welka
suivra bien évidemment
Thomas on va enfin passer à toi il a
attendu patiemment pendant tout le temps
je suis dans les startings depuis 45
minutes je suis plus que près là
bloqué dedans
il va nous parler de la SSI sous-estern
conférence avec
je te laisse introduire les grandes
équipes tout ça et puis on va on va
parler c'est toujours une grosse
conférence hein
les plus connues beaucoup de gros
programmes une conférence qui va
accueillir beaucoup de gros prospects
fraîchement cette année vous allez voir
après je vous ai présenté que du 5
étoiles et j'ai dû en éliminer
quelques-uns donc il y a beaucoup de
grosses également on peut compter auburn
qui vient de poser jabarit Smith à la
draft on a Tennessee qui vient de poser
qui va recruter 3 5 étoiles on a ls you
Florida etc beaucoup de gros programmes
mené par Kentucky qui est sûrement le
plus gros programme de cette conférence
qui a des vraies cartes à jouer cette
année du côté de la NCA avec un effectif
très très solide de recrues 5 étoiles
qu'on va aborder plus tard en crise
Livingston et quason Wallace
on a Oscar tribué toujours au poste de
pivot qui est un des un des Contenders
pour une petite de genre de l'année on a
servi Wheeler à la main on a Jacob
topping qui a fait une très très grosse
précision et qui pourra avoir une
Breakout season cette année qui est
vraiment très intéressant la Damian
Collins également qui était un fresh 25
étoiles l'an passé qui a beaucoup à
proposer cette année donc grosse
effectif coach c'est un peu
l'interrogation toujours
coaching
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de
lui mettre une petite balle perdue le
j'ai mis le futur mal utilisé parce que
c'est un peu le problème à chaque fois
on attend beaucoup on pense l'année
dernière à ta taille Washington et il a
fallu en fait au cours de circonstances
pour qu'ils se retrouvent avec le ballon
dans les mains ce bon vieux taille et se
joue le jour des roquettes
du coup gros prospect 5 étoiles un des
meilleurs prospects 5 étoiles qui vient
du Texas de Richardson où il évolue avec
un autre prospect de d'Alabama
d'ailleurs avec Ryan Griffen que j'aime
aussi énormément donc on est sur sur un
Guard post 1 2 c'est vraiment un joueur
qui peut évoluer aux deux potes de Guard
donc 6 3 une envergure de quasiment 2 m
les mêmes mensurations d'un joueur qui
les souvent comparé je roule l'idée
exactement les mêmes mensurations
quasiment on est sur un joueur vraiment
déjà très mature qui va apporter
directement à Kentucky devrait titulaire
à côté de sa vieweller donc il devrait
évoluer au poste 2 on est sur un joueur
qui brille premièrement par sa défense
c'est un joueur vraiment qui qui vit par
la défense qui vit pour la défense et
qui a envie de défendre tout simplement
à chaque match il va défendre le
meilleur attaquant adverse c'est un
joueur qui est comme je l'ai dit très
mature dans son jeu il s'est défend très
bien que ce soit off ball un ball il est
toujours concentré il peut contrer il
intercepte il fait beaucoup de belles
choses genre comme j'ai dit vraiment
concentré donc il va être positif très
très rapidement en NCA et même après
ensuite en NBA je pense que c'est
vraiment un joueur solide de ce point de
vue là en attaque il offre également
beaucoup de certitudes c'est un bon
shooter
l'année dernière plutôt déjà sur du 35
36% sur du volume intéressant donc il va
pouvoir être utilisé offball à côté de
sa vie Wheeler à côté de chez moi qui va
avoir beaucoup de ballons donc il va
pouvoir mettre du 3 points il y a une
bonne range de tir et légalement capable
de tirer après le riz que soit 3 francs
ou à 1200 trop facilement ses spot même
si c'est pas forcément sur athlète sur
le premier pas et là il a trouvé ses
spots toujours sous contrôle vraiment le
genre sous contrôle en attaque comme on
défense et c'est pour saupoudrer tout ça
un vrai bon passeur c'est au minimum un
excellent facilitateur de jeu c'est le
rôle qu'il aura principalement cette
année et qui aura déjà deux gros
porteurs de balle à côté de lui qui va
avoir beaucoup de ballons au poste et ça
vire Wheeler qui va mener l'attaque donc
quand il aura la balle entre les mains
il va pouvoir faciliter tout ça et quand
il aura des petites répétitions en tant
que que porteur de balles sur pick and
roll il pourra en faire également des
bonnes choses c'est pas ses mains droite
main gauche
envoyer son son bigalle donc vraiment un
joueur très très complet très très fort
déjà qui va apporter beaucoup je pense
du côté de Kentucky de cette saison
alors on sait les prospects de Kinte qui
ces dernières saisons ont connu des
destins parfois aux antipodes on a
évoqué tout à l'heure tu as été
Washington donc qui a un petit peu des
difficultés à exister sous cahiers Paris
on pense avant
notre ami qui est parti au Clippers en
59e position qui a été annoncée loterie
et qui finalement chuté tout au long de
l'année
comment il s'appelle
donc il y a toujours un petit puis même
encore l'année d'avant avec le joueur de
NX
ouais qui voilà c'est toujours des
joueurs j'ai l'impression avec une on se
demande toujours mais
qu'est-ce qui va vraiment c'est toujours
la même question et moi j'ai un peu peur
sur le profil de je te dis comme je le
pense parce que comme tu l'as dit je
trouve que c'est un voie intelligent et
qui force pas beaucoup et j'ai
l'impression qu'il peut peut-être
disparaître à cause de ça aussi si c'est
un peu ma crainte moi est-ce que tu as
des éléments pour me rassurer là-dessus
pour te rassurer je pense que je pense
que ça passerait je pense que c'est un
genre quand même beaucoup de certitudes
aux yeux des scouts c'est genre qui va
amener défense directement qui va
défendre comme je l'ai dit plus gros le
plus gros joueur adverse sur les lignes
extérieures à défendre 1 2 limites 3 sur
les petits 3 ncpe fonctionnement qu'il
est déjà encore vraiment mature c'est un
joueur donc à beaucoup de certitudes il
a quasiment aucun défaut dans son jeu il
va défendre le plomb il va mettre ses
trois points il va pouvoir créer de
temps en temps qu'on va lui demander
donc il apporte trop de certitude pour
moi NBA je pense que c'est un joueur qui
je l'aime bien j'aime bien ce côté
leader également sur terrain leader
défensif des hommes dès sa première
pardon un joueur qui défend le plus long
délice school c'est également assez peu
commun donc je pense vraiment qu'il a
qu'il porte beaucoup de certitudes avec
du vrai talent offensif que ce soit la
passe ou au tir même sur la création il
s'est un peu tout faire il a aucun vrai
défaut contrairement par exemple un
passé qui est pas un super défenseur qui
est déjà un peu plus vieux qui a pas un
super physique je pense que kaison voilà
ça apporte vraiment beaucoup de choses
sur lesquelles sur lesquels il sera dur
de fermer les yeux tout simplement
Alex il y a deux choses en fait pierre
c'est que
premièrement je pense que ces joueurs là
on a du mal à les évaluer parce que
parce que on prend trop en compte le
contexte Kentucky c'est pas trop quoi
faire de cette année mais Thomas il a vu
pas mal de High School et c'est
l'avantage d'avoir des gars dans
l'équipe comme comme Thomas et Mathias
qui voit des du contexte avant qui aide
généralement évolué Emmanuel quickly
il était fort écoute tu vois
il se crée son tir et rentrer ses tiens
etc
et deuxièmement
et d'un contrairement à tout quasiment
tous les prospects qui pourraient passer
par là je pense que c'est un bon
contexte pour qui
parce que je pense que c'est pas un prêt
Méribel
underi ma théorie c'est que c'est une
sorte de
tranquillo de jouer au Lidl
effectivement c'est une belle
comparaison
il y a ça veut dire Wheeler qui va se
charger des trucs chiants
et lui va montrer que ses qualités du
tir de la grosse défense et de
l'intensité des intangibles tu vois il y
a un gros moteur il est intense
franchement
je pense que s'il avait été mis en
situation d'avoir la balle dans le
contexte de Kentucky ça aurait été
peut-être plus difficile il aurait dû
forcer des tirs et ça aurait été pas
forcément lui faire
lui faire servir alors que là alors
certes c'est un profil qui est un peu
qui est peu commun j'en parlais tout à
l'heure de Sega qui sont des potentiels
un peu fluendy mais plus sur les lignes
arrières mais avec cette aire de mon
primey en fait c'est généralement un
gars qui va faire 2 mètres de mètres 3
et qui a un grand ailier et ben c'est un
profil qui se recherche de plus en plus
et qui va et qui et qui va être de plus
en plus commun je pense dans les années
à venir NBA donc je pense que Kasan
Wallace peut-être qu'il sera sous drafté
tu as raison
peut-être que parce qu'il y a d'autres
gars qui vont jouer primary qui vont
montrer plus de trucs ils vont ils vont
passer devant mais par contre je suis
quasiment je suis assez sûr que enfin ce
sera une des valeurs sûres du premier
tour même si franchement pour moi
ok
le fait qu'il est moins là-bas et que
c'est vrai que d'être un bol dominante
qui s'est l'utiliser c'est quand même
assez évaluable dans dans les drafts
on a fait le tour donc gros défenseur
gros prospect qui
étrangement peut-être arrive dans un bon
contexte à Kentucky on reste à Kentucky
on va apprendre ça Thomas dis-moi on
peut rester toujours chez les Bleus
enchaîner avec Chris Livingston donc
Élie et Croon donc dans la même ville
que hollywan James donc qui joue à oki
de cette année dans une équipe de cul
avec toujours pas mal de prospects
notamment qui a fait une vraie bonne
saison avec du jeu d'Amine c'est
finalement donc Chris lemmingston c'est
un poste 3 déjà mature physiquement 1m98
quasiment 100 kg donc vraiment un joueur
solide c'est un joueur qui s'est un peu
tout fait avec allemand c'est un genre
qui va pouvoir bien défendre en NCA
c'est pas forcément l'athlète le plus
fort latéralement mais va pouvoir
défendre sur du petit cadre sur du 3
peut-être sur du 2 c'est la chose que
j'ai envie de voir s'il peut défendre un
peu plus petit que sa taille sinon c'est
un joueur qui a fortement amélioré son
shoot cette dernière saison je trouve il
a vraiment une grosse grosse range de
tir il tirent rarement dans les corner
pour l'instant mais il tire très souvent
deux trois mètres derrière la ligne
plein axe donc j'ai hâte de voir s'il va
rentrer ses tirs cette année je pense
que c'est un joueur que vous entourent
des 35% sa projection que je donnerais
sur cette saison Etienne te dit s'il
rentre s'étire et pour avoir du temps de
jeu s'il est rentré pas dans une équipe
et là où il y aura pas la balle comme on
l'a vu déjà calesona ou à la s'il aura
encore moins donc s'il rentre pas
s'étire il aura temps de jeu forcément
plus compliqué sinon c'est un joueur qui
a montré en High School pour faire pas
mal de choses il est capable d'aller au
cirque même si j'aimerais qu'il y aille
un peu plus je pense les qualités
suffisantes pour un premier pas
intéressant il est physique je trouve
qu'il joue pas assez sur il a pas assez
chaud sur cette domination physique on a
eu School à mon sens mais sinon on est
sur un bon shotmaker à mi distance à
trois points il s'est créé ses tir le
mécanique fluide il a un bon feuille de
ouais et donc c'est vraiment intéressant
c'est un passeur également plus que
correct pour pour aligner un ailier de
son âge pardon il s'est distribué on l'a
vu par moment sur sur un peu de pick and
roll vu qu'il est menaçant sur son
existence menaçant à trois points donc
il peut trouver son big par moment donc
un prospect assez complet pareil pas
forcément énormément de défauts un
joueur qui qui se met en évidence cette
Anakin si je foutent bien sinon ça
serait un peu un peu plus compliqué mais
un vrai prospect à surveiller cette
année
moi dans tout ce que tu as dit c'est
très très intéressant j'ai l'impression
qu'il est bon partout mais ce qui il a
des qualités et une parce que c'est ça
qui est recherché souvent lors des draft
c'est pas un bon défenseur mais c'est
pas un défenseur relique il y a eu les
mensurations en plus il faut sortir il y
a quelques jours il a peine très grand
envergure en plus comme quason Wallace
donc pour un délai c'est encore plus
plus dérangeant sera un défenseur solide
mais peut-être pas Lite c'est un shooter
qui commence à être solide donc c'est
peut-être le le secteur de jeu où il a
le plus de potentiel pasteur il aura pas
la balle à Kentucky il aura pas non plus
en NBA je pense donc je pense qu'il peut
vraiment devenir un bonugaille un joueur
qui c'est un peu tout faire qui va
défendre qui va shooter qui va pouvoir
driver qui va pouvoir créer son petit
shoot mais arrêter 56 secondes sur
l'horloge et qui va se retrouver que la
patate chaude il va pas ralentir le jeu
de son équipe donc c'est faire pas mal
de choses mais peut-être rien d'élite
donc je pense pas que ce soit un top top
prospect qui va partir top 10 top 15
mais dans un premier tour ça sera ça
sera totalement je pense que c'est une
bonne saison
alors encore une fois comme tous les
joueurs dont on parle par mes welcards
je les ai moins vu que que
je trouve qu'il a
il a moins de moteur que que en fait
je vais avoir besoin de gala comme en
fait je suis complètement marrant parce
que je les regarde après je suis allé
voir le scooting enfin le prescooting
report qui avait écrit Thomas qui a fait
un article sur les Héli à suivre et
c'est exactement ça quoi s'il rentre pas
s'étire je vois pas l'intérêt que que je
peux avoir à suivre ce joueur pour la
draft parce qu'il va il va pas poser la
balle au sol
beaucoup même s'il en avait l'occasion
je suis pas sûr qu'il pourrait
énormément le faire
ce qui peut faire moi je trouve que son
corps il est pas terminé en revanche je
trouve que je trouve qu'il peut ajouter
beaucoup beaucoup de poids et il a il a
je trouve qu'il a un peu un corps d'ado
avec une tu vois il a déjà la carrure
pour ajouter du poids donc peut-être que
ça ça peut changer pas mal de choses
dans son jeu notamment le nombre de
positions qui peut défendre
notamment le les options qui peut avoir
offensivement pour se créer de l'espace
et ce genre de choses
mais sinon je suis un peu plus mesuré
sur Livingston
parce que j'ai pas vu le même le la même
arme que kaizenwallace qui est qui pour
moi est pas voilà qui va peut-être
jamais vraiment faire la différence tout
seul mais par contre
quel envie de bouffer l'autre quoi et
linston il l'a pas en tout cas je l'ai
pas vu
d'autant plus que comme disait Thomas
il soulignait le fait qu'il a du mal à
imposer son physique alors est-ce que
déjà s'il avait pas ce défaut là en
school ça va pas être un peu encore plus
majoré à l'échelon supérieur c'est un
peu aussi après il va prendre du poids
c'est sûr et je te dis moi vu sa carrure
à mon avis il va prendre beaucoup de
poids pour le coup ça devrait être parce
que voilà s'il est terminé physiquement
tu vois mais
Livingston il a il peut prendre 10 kg je
pense donc
peut-être que ça peut changer tu vois
peut-être qu'il était pas il était pas à
l'aise par rapport même si en High
School bon il y a un peu de tout quoi
mais
ouais non je
je suis pas un grand fan après le
contexte général Kentucky on va lui
demander de mettre des tirs et peut-être
d'aller
un peu chatouiller le rebond offensif
qui a hyper faire ça parfois
Thomas où est-ce qu'on va maintenant
dis-nous tout on peut aller on peut
aller du côté du côté d'archanges
pourquoi pas avec avec mix Smith le l'un
des plus gros prospects de cette cuvée
donc notre ami qui arrive à Arkansas
dans une dans une grosse grosse cuvée
avec Jordan walk avec Anthony black
beaucoup de grosses gros prospect
pendant cette année du côté de l'arc de
SAS il vient il vient de l'Arcane ça
c'est également il était à North Little
Rock High School avec quel elwer qui est
allé du côté de Oregon également
prospect 5 étoiles donc le pivot cette
relation lui a permis vraiment de créer
un très bon jeu très bon jeu à deux avec
son bio c'est un vrai vrai bon passeur
prend c'est un combo Guard post-2 voilà
c'est un six six force x-five donc
vraiment très très intéressant c'est un
joueur qui a également beaucoup de
qualité offensives c'est principalement
là qu'on va qu'on va l'attendre il va
pouvoir run la taille d'Arkansas très
très tôt c'est un bon shotmaker trois
points mi distance c'est vraiment très
solide
il a un premier pas correct mais il a il
a encore long Gilling c'est pas le
joueur qui va mettre le plus de densité
au cerf pour aller finir au contact mais
pour pallier pour pallier ce défaut là
déjà un super flotteur et qui peut
envoyer à très longue distance dès qu'on
arrive sur la ligne de lancer Franck
pour envoyer son flotteur donc c'est
très intéressant donc il va pouvoir
produire beaucoup d'attaques pour
arc-en-ciel s'il va scorer il va passer
je suis pas étonné si il va mettre 15 16
17 fois par match avec potentiellement
trois quatre passes ça va jouer beaucoup
de transition avec avec quoi le je sais
pas quoi à ses côtés donc donc c'est
très intéressant défensivement c'est pas
un je vous vois pas en défenseur
incroyable mais c'est un joueur qui
faisait déjà les efforts en high
schoolisme on serait plutôt intéressant
il est long il a une grande envergure il
peut gêner c'est un c'est un vrai leader
je trouve sur le terrain s'il est vocal
en défense en attaque et je pense que
vraiment il aura cette ce côté
compétitif qui va même si c'est pas un
défenseur et c'est pas forcément ce
qu'on va attendre de lui on va plus
l'attendre d'un côté offensif je pense
qu'il sera toujours là pour pour essayer
de faire gagner son équipe en montrant
l'exemple en fait
c'est un prospect qui annoncé quand même
très très haut souvent enfin moi je l'ai
souvent vu dans les loteries nyxmus
c'est dans les mêmes dans les 10 souvent
assez souvent là pour l'instant
qu'est-ce qui fait de lui
un prospect loterie justement pour
l'instant son bagage offensif complet
sont sa capacité à mettre des tirs à
trois points à mi distance il est très
long comme je l'ai dit il peut shooter
sur la tête de beaucoup de défenseurs
donc il est très long il peut shooter
sur la tête de quasiment n'importe qui
gros flotteur donc à part ça son manque
de finition au Cercle c'est ce qu'on va
attendre de lui comme progress cette
année et c'est de mieux finir avec mon
contact il a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
de points positifs offensivement c'est
déjà un vrai vrai gros shooter donc si
je faisais à 37 38 quasiment 40% c'est
quand je serai pas du tout étonné donc
c'est également très très bon shooter de
4 donc il va pouvoir jouer au football
quand Anthony black par exemple aura la
balle c'est très intéressant très bon
passeur pour sa taille pour un poste 2
contrairement par exemple au un poste de
ces dernières années à charpe à Green
Anthony Edwards c'est vraiment déjà un
purpasseur donc il va pouvoir jouer ce 1
CE2 il est utilisable dans beaucoup de
systèmes offensifs Peugeot Peugeot avec
la balle peut scorer peut passer
vraiment gros Prosp offensif qui est pas
mauvais en défense qui a un bon leader
et la porte il apporte un vrai niveau
général en fait il va pouvoir le montrer
très tôt cette année à Arkansas je pense
qu'il était très bon notamment il était
vraiment solide sur
arc-en-ciel ça fait un petit tour
d'Europe pas mal c'est vraiment faire
remarquer je crois qu'il a quasiment à
20 ans de moyenne donc c'était vraiment
déjà très solide et on a vu les prémices
de ce qui va pouvoir faire cette année
je pense
du scoring à fond je pense que ça va
être sa responsabilité première et en
fait j'ai été
hyper impressionné par sa coordination
parce que Thomas dit il a un peu du mal
au SARC ouais ok mais il sait des accès
en fait
il s'adapte tellement vite à ce que lui
propose la défense tu vois il a pas de
plan en fait son plan c'est marqué et il
y arrive à chaque fois et
en gros tu as la défense qui change et
lui il va s'adapter il va faire le
contremoude il a une palette technique
qui est extraordinaire et que ce soit au
niveau des appuis ou que ce soit au
niveau de du de la dextérité du dribble
de la finition il a un touché de de
ballon enfin il a un instinct en fait
offensif qui est assez fou donc rien que
ça
taille
oui c'est un TOP 10 tu vois pas chier
c'est
ça paraît assez clair et maintenant
il va devoir prendre en main dans une
conférence très physique
donc c'est un super test
c'est un super test parce que
les joueurs les joueurs qui sont avec
lui les deux autres freshman qui sont
arrivés qui sont eux aussi attendus dans
le top 20 de la draft on parle vite fait
Antony black alors Anthony black faut
qu'il a à la cantoche pour être devant
mais c'est un grand meneur de maître qui
est pas hyper qui est du coup pas du
tout scorer pour le coup mais qui aide
son équipe de plein d'autres manières
que ce soit défensivement mais surtout
un mode vision de jeu des petites choses
et surtout Jordan watch qui est
extraordinaire qui a du charisme en plus
avec sa tête là incroyable
franchement
c'est même pas il a pas de position tu
vois il peut il peut tout jouer il ça va
être l'homme à tout faire de cette
équipe c'est un gars qui doit faire quoi
de 0,12
il prend le rebond il va remonter le
ballon
Jordan moi je shoot à 3 points il est
top 10 donc
donc mais en fin de match je pense que
c'est Nick Smith qui aura la balle tu
vois quand il faudra marquer des paniers
importants
donc ouais je trouve que j'aimerais bien
le voir
en fait cette année pour moi elle va
déterminer si c'est un gars qui est avec
le ballon numéro 1 ou si c'est un second
cas je parle au plus haut niveau tu vois
parce que c'est le meilleur joueur de
ton équipe ou est-ce que c'est le
deuxième meilleur joueur est-ce que et
du coup on va le voir avec le ballon
mais j'aimerais bien offball le voir
Utiliser tu vois avec du pindown avec
après un renversement de jeu ce genre de
choses pour voilà je veux voir où il est
le meilleur en fait où il apporte le
plus par rapport à un joueur moyen
ça marche
est-ce que la au niveau défensif on a
dit c'est moins bien
pas de quoi mettre de ralphine non plus
quand même non c'est pour un gros genre
francif c'est
gravité assez haut et que ça peut poser
des problèmes sur les petits les petits
dragsters
supérieur ok Thomas dis-nous tu fais GPS
encore une fois
le GPS peut se poser peut se poser en
Caroline du Sud pour pour Monsieur DJ
Jackson et ben on est parti pour 10 le
GG le good game exactement donc Jackson
qui qui s'est reclassifié qui était dans
la classe dans la classe 2023 donc qui
était du côté du High School donc un
joueur vraiment vraiment très
impressionnant très qui laisse présager
beaucoup beaucoup de potentiels vraiment
un joueur très très intrigant il a fini
la saison High School avec un très très
gros aywa Biel il était dans une forte
équipe avec Robert dellingham et adéno
loway de Guard très bon bolenders qui
savent un peu tout faire donc c'était
vraiment les patrons de l'équipe et lui
il était là un peu comme comme intérieur
très fort finisseur au Cercle bon
athlète ils finissait vraiment son
problème il court vraiment très très
bien donc transition et aucun problème
ça l'envoyait au lobe dans tous les sens
c'est je l'ai pas dit ça c'est un six
nine donc il va jouer du côté de South
Caroline il avait d'abord commis pour
l'an prochain du côté de North carliner
du coup faire un petit un petit voyage
vers le sud et Jackson il a beaucoup
montré halial est-ce qu'il avait un peu
moins montré en saison des flashs qui
sont ultra très très grands pour sa
taille c'est qu'il a vraiment un super
bundle donc pour sa taille ça rend très
très impressionnant il est capable
d'aller au cercle en avait un il est
capable de créer son midrange en AV1 il
envoie des steppes à 4 points par moment
donc c'est vraiment ultra impressionnant
et ce en deux lui ouvre tellement de
possibilités c'est c'est vraiment
sa plus grosse qualité et ensuite donc
on l'a vu il a plutôt été pas trop mal
efficace notamment à mi distance il a il
donne mécanique de tir vraiment très
propre donc à 1200 si il est capable
d'aller au cercle il est athlétique à
trois points ça rentre de plus en plus
également donc on aura beaucoup de
responsabilités cette année sûrement du
côté de ça parce que là si il montre
pouvoir rentrer pas mal de choses des
shoots compliquées à midi distance à
trois points aller au cercle en plus
c'est un bon défenseur il est à deux
comptes par match lors de l'ew B il me
semble même que c'est le meilleur
contraire de l'événement en tout donc
vraiment très impressionnant je vais
l'attendre sur de la défense sur plus
petit sur du niveau ancien dans une
grosse conférence vu qu'en High School
c'est toujours plus simple même quand on
est grand qu'on est assez mobile de
défendre sur du plus petit donc c'est
vraiment la chose que je vais regarder
mais ça peut être un poste 4 bon
créateur de tir le handle lui offre
également des petites qualités de
passeurs il y a une vision de jeu
intéressant qui peut finir les actions
il peut les créer par lui-même il peut
défendre je pense à un vrai bon niveau
donc prospect ultra intrigant peut-être
des prospects les plus les plus
intrigants de l'année je pense du coup
d'être sauf Carline
si je crois il n'y a pas encore
17 ans ouais c'est ça
est-ce que tu l'avais vu dans un autre
contexte avec qui mieux c'est ou pas ah
ouais mais il avait peu joué il était au
18 au Mexique il me semble qu'il avait
joué que deux matchs j'ai regardé tous
les matchs de la petite balade mexicaine
du coup j'étais un peu déçu vu que on
l'avait vu que deux fois il me semble
qu'il fait un 8 sur 8 au tir le premier
match parce que comme ça après ça donne
mais du coup on n'a pas vu grand chose
c'était beaucoup de bien qu'on contrat à
ta coup donc on attend d'avoir plus
cette année où il prend vraiment montrer
beaucoup de choses
c'est un peu le cliché de la SCI à
savoir le basket et secondaire et c'est
des c'est un peu des bruitages
d'Américains de foot mais
je t'avoue que j'ai pas étudié le
contexte autour de DJ Jackson donc je
vais pas pouvoir éclairer là-dessus je
sais pas si Thomas il sait ce qu'il y a
autour
en l'occurrence
que j'étais absorbé parce que j'ai
étudié vite quand même pour dire que je
remplace Hugues un peu
et du coup je connaissais pas du tout
j'ai dit que Jackson et en fait j'étais
absorbé il est fascinant quoi je trouve
que il domine physiquement alors que ça
se voit tellement qu'il est pas fini
il sait pas encore courir correctement
je suis sûr qu'il sait pas encore courir
correctement je suis sûr qu'il peut
encore être plus mobile que ça alors
qu'il est déjà plus mobile que ces
adversaires directs tu vois ce que je
veux dire et donc
alors cette année tu vois je pense qu'il
va être raté il y a moyen qui soit sous
drafté parce que cette année elle va
être compliqué pour lui il va pas être
dans une grosse fac il y a moyen qui
joue s'il y a moyen qu'il soit pas
forcément 100% efficace j'aimerais bien
savoir s'il peut jouer 4 s'il est ce
qu'on a vu à halliwebiel est vrai en
fait si il peut
avoir un mi distance au moins spot-up à
trois points en corner tu vois
si peu de driver son adversaire directe
depuis le périmètre ce genre de choses
s'il peut vraiment jouer 4 en NBA avec
une vraie mobilité parce que le handle
est bon pour son âge et sa taille mais
c'est quand même pas du tout un dol de 4
NBA pour l'instant donc voilà j'aimerais
bien voir ça cette année mais par contre
en fait une des choses que la NBA fait
le mieux je pensais à ça la dernière
fois en regardant courir bol Paul bol il
sortait d'origon
moi je les ai pas faire une course
arrière tu vois je disais gros va tout
droit retourne chez toi après tu vois
chaque chose en son temps et là il est
incroyable Il court il court hyper
fluide etc est-ce que fait de mieux la
NBA c'est vraiment de développer les les
capacités de coordination athlétique les
joueurs et leurs forces aussi tu vois
Olivier Sart Olivier serre c'est une
dinguerie tu vois il est devenu hyper
fort alors aussi la pâte de
Fort contrat NBA etc c'est devenu un
joueur complètement différent et donc
quand tu vois ça et que tu prends
Jackson comme il est déjà c'est à dire
une brutasse qui
je pense qu'il peut avoir un physique à
la déballer tu vois une fille
comme ça après il est pas très grand non
enfin moi je pense que justement
j'aimerais bien voir si grandis pas je
pense qu'il pense qu'il y a moyen
qui finissent à 2 mètres 8 tu vois parce
que si c'est pivot de mètres 4 c'était
là un peu mon interrogation pour la
projection en fait parce que il a quand
même pas beaucoup non plus à part d'être
un très très fort shooter la porte
d'entrée semble assez mince quoi
bien sûr mais je pense qu'il grandit
encore
bah oui après c'est un des plus jeunes
on l'a dit il a 17 ans donc il peut
encore prendre facile de 16 ans
et puis j'ai adoré son interview j'ai
regardé il a fait une interview il y a
trois jours après saison 6 Carolina
[ __ ] 17 ans il est bon franchement il
est bon tu vois il est il est à l'air il
est il fait des réponses de plus de deux
phrases
et non j'aime bien le garçon je suis
assez fan
du coup on va tous regarder on va pas se
faire plaisir niveau basket mais on va
regarder ce score
il va avoir des gros tests en tout cas
si il sort des belles pertes mais c'est
typiquement le genre de gars tu vois il
y a des gens qui vont suragir ils vont
l'enlever de leur moque en fin décembre
parce qu'il va faire une un début de
saison nul évidemment tu vois
qui va pas être bon alors j'aimerais
bien qu'il soit bon dès le début de
saison super Noël et puis après il va
faire un mois de février où il va mettre
il va tourner en 15 10 à 60 % et [ __ ]
c'est logique
Thomas est-ce que maintenant on n'irait
pas du côté des vols du Tennessee
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas pour parler de
Julian Philippe donc Julian Philippe
c'est un ailier de mettre 3 de mètres 4
vraiment vraiment très longs il doit
faire 90 kg environ et je vois cette
année dans le gros programme de ligne
Academy avec beaucoup de gros prospects
Jordan walk
omabe you blue j'ai toujours pas comment
on le prononce et le nom avec lequel
j'ai le plus de mal je crois il joue
également avec tarifri de le commit le
comique Michigan donc un vrai un vrai
bon programme il jouait donc trois
ailiers dans l'équipe au mobilier Jordan
watch Julian Philippe trois élites de
mettre 3 de mètres 4 tous bons défenseur
c'est vraiment ce qu'il apporte
principalement pour l'instant c'est un
genre encore vraiment très brut c'est le
c'est le joueur le plus beau de un des
gens les plus brutes de la cuvée je
pense défensivement il apporte pas mal
de choses il est très long il est assez
concentré il peut il peut suivre des
shooters etc sans prendre sans prendre
trop d'écran sans trop perdre son joueur
c'est assez intéressant sur l'homme il
est également assez bon il est long il
peut contrer il peut intercepter peut
faire pas mal de choses maintenant
offensivement c'est c'est plus douteux
je l'ai un peu pris comme mon sixième
joueur un peu sur lequel je vais avoir
des petites questions et sur lesquelles
j'ai hâte de voir ce qui va nous
proposer cette année justement
surveiller son toucher au cercle qui
n'est pour l'instant pas très bon il a
des mains il a des mains un peu un peu
carrées par moment comme on dit Picard
au foot moitié je sais pas si ça se dit
trop mais aujourd'hui on va l'employer
apparemment ça tape un peu un peu la
planche très fortement pas mal de gros
écarts le shoot est une fluidité
correcte par moment mais la mécanique
est pas encore totalement fixée voilà ça
va réaccord un petit peu donc la
réussite est pas encore là clairement
c'est un joueur qui dont je vais
attendre un développement peut-être un
peu plus long que les autres avec un
profil de long et lié qui peut vraiment
bien défendre au plus haut niveau je
pense il va falloir développer le jeu
offensif continuer de développer le 3
points je pense que ça peut devenir un
shooter correct au moins au fil au fil
des années et essayer de c'est un bon
athlète je l'ai pas précisé bon premier
pas vrai bon athlète long donc je pense
que quand il va pouvoir continuer de
développer son 3 points sur de l'attaque
de Clausa ou ensuite il va pouvoir aller
finir au cercle en force et également
une menace de l'Aube donc je trouve que
c'est un joueur intéressant à suivre
peut-être un peu plus sur le long terme
mais vrai prospects encore du côté de
Tennessee cette année pas trop de
responsabilité pour lui je pense il
faudra pas lui mettre trop de pression
mais mes petit à petit préfèrent ils
préfèrent sa place
est-ce que Alex est pas un peu le cliché
du prospect de Tennessee
ben alors non parce que en fait
peut-être que c'est juste ce que j'ai vu
moi mais moi je trouve que par rapport à
tous les ailiers de la liste de Thomas
là
pas celle du site mais ce dont on parle
ce soir donc Jackson Livingston Miller
donc par la presse
je trouve qu'il a il a un vrai handle
mais peut-être que c'est juste moi mais
je trouve qu'il a de l'intéressant tu
vois et
ça fait une différence assez grande
parce que je me dis bah [ __ ] tiens
peut-être qu'avec ça
il va pouvoir
porter le ballon sur deux trois
picanerolles par match le genre de truc
c'est pas le style de rickbard
c'était plus par rapport à ça ma
question c'est à dire que on sait que
c'est
je pense Thomas a raison je pense que
Thomas raison il va rester
rester peut-être plus d'un an quoi
mais mais cette année il a un bon il a
un bon contexte parce que il a des
joueurs expérimentés sur ces positions
3-4 il y a NK moi
et il a triple
qui est
un prospect d'ailleurs
et en fait à part ces deux-là il y a un
il y a un DJ Jefferson je sais pas ce
qu'il vaut qui est freshman qui joue
poste 3 je pense et sinon mais lui tu
vois il devrait avoir au moins c'est 20
minutes assuré quoi parce que une cam à
moi tu le fais pas jouer 35 minutes
donc
non je pense que il aura un bon contexte
et j'aimerais bien le voir
ouais j'aimerais bien le voir porter un
peu le ballon
et
qui doivent prendre des décisions pour
le mettre à l'épreuve du feu quoi prise
de décision alors après voilà ils ont
senti à mauvaiscovis Santiago vescovi
aura beaucoup le ballon parce que c'est
un très bon joueur
expérimenté c'est l'assurance touriste à
l'arrière de cette équipe de tennis
[Musique]
on finit avec toi Thomas avec
Brandon Miller
c'est un peu perturbant vas-y
du côté d'Alabama voilà
exactement le pull donc grand forward de
médecins longiligne pareil il doit faire
dans les 90 95 kg c'est un bon athlète
vertical notamment fait parler lui par
Dunky sur un défenseur mais c'est pas un
joueur qu'un excellent premier pas donc
il peut avoir quelques difficultés à
créer de la séparation pour aller au
cercle ou même pour se créer par moment
un petit mi distance c'est un
topshotmaker il est grand très long donc
même en créant petit séparation à mi
distance il va pouvoir réussir à rentrer
des shoots c'est un joueur qui tirait
pas trop à trois points par exemple ally
qu'il a fait l'an dernier je crois qu'il
est sur 1,5 de tentatives par match mais
qui a pris cette année sur son seigneur
beaucoup plus de trois points petit à
petit il a pris du volume il a pas une
super mécanique une mécanique qui part
pas mal en avant donc qui est lâché
assez basse et je le trouve plutôt
efficace et je pense que ça peut être un
shooter assez fiable plutôt assez
rapidement du côté d'album à cette année
défensivement défensivement on a un
genre qui défend pas énormément ça
dépend ça dépend des situations mais
c'est un high school c'était pas la
folie peu d'efforts mais pourtant il a
des vrais capacités il a des mains très
actives au poste vu qu'il est un petit
peu en manque de poids il peut se faire
un peu bouger vu qu'il jouait 5
naturellement quand tu fais 6 9 en ice
School il jouait 5 du coup il pouvait se
faire un peu bouger par moment mais il
démarre très active il arrivait à
compenser il est très long donc il
arrive à contrer également les voyait
bien et je l'ai mis dans dans l'article
il est sur deux interceptions de compte
quasiment donc c'est un joueur qui a du
potentiel défensif du potentiel défensif
il se met vraiment dans la tête de
défendre offensivement il a beaucoup de
talents capables de mettre des gros
tiramis distance capable de créer son
tir à trois points de sanctionner en
quatre chaînes shoots je vais l'attendre
sur un peu plus d'attaque de panier en
sur des lignes vraiment vraiment claires
en attaque de closaz ça peut vraiment le
faire mais je veux voir s'il est capable
d'attaquer le panier vraiment en
contraint s'il est capable de jouer son
petit pick and roll pour aller au cercle
c'est un vrai bon prospect du côté de du
côté d'Alabama
alors j'ai mis physique de rêve c'est
par rapport justement à sa longueur
parce que c'est un genre de profil que
la NBA aime bien les grands tout mince
comme ça
dans le contexte à la mama là encore un
bon coach avec notre ami Neto
qu'est-ce que ça va donner cette année
on sait que c'est généralement ça c'est
un jeu assez moderne avec beaucoup de
spaceing est-ce que il va se louer
là-dedans Alex
oui oui avec l'autre
l'autre gars dont tu parlais tout à
l'heure là
que j'ai bien aimé un
grand chose mais bref vraiment longueur
aussi ouais je pense que alors
ouais il y a un garde expérimenté
Sears il y a ni Marie Burnett
qui a beaucoup approuvé
pas ma connaissance
et puis surtout il y a un gros rime
Runner pro de fin protecteur de cercle
avec Médiaco
et du coup et du coup du coup les
ailiers ont un peu moins de boulot moi
je vais l'attendre défensivement par
contre en fait ce Brandon Miller parce
que sa plus-value en fait je trouve en
fait je trouve que son vraiment Thomas
on a parlé sont lâché de ballon là son
shoot un peu chaud de Marion un peu bas
là
alors plus efficace
[Musique]
ça annule complètement son avantage de
taille et de longueur
et j'ai vraiment peur que si ça bouge
pas
ça ne puisse pas être compatible avec
une efficacité à haut niveau
parce qu'on a du mal à se rendre compte
mais en school ils sont vachement de
temps ils sont il était vachement plus
grand que tout le monde donc c'était
facile pour lui d'armer ses tirs que ce
soit une distance et à trois points là
il aura un peu moins d'espace encore
plus en sec ou en SSC où il y a des
athlètes
en NBA c'est encore autre chose donc il
y a plus d'espace mais il y a plus des
athlètes et il faut lâcher vite quoi il
faut lâcher vite il faut lâcher haut au
moins l'un des deux c'est mieux c'est
les deux donc
je suis un peu inquiet sur son tir et
donc je me dis que ça plus value ça peut
être la protection de cercle en deuxième
rideau tu vois loin du sel en vision etc
pour ça il va falloir qu'il soit
impliqué je pense que l'autre il peut
lui dire enfin c'est un coach
intelligent aussi c'est ce que les
prospects doivent apporter pour aller à
une bière donc
mais sinon ouais je suis d'accord avec
le le constat qui a fait qui a fait
Thomas après une seule chose que j'ai
ajouté il est un peu plus vieux je crois
que les autres c'est un fresh
donc ça moi j'aime pas par exemple
pas parce que juste il est plus vieux
mais ça veut dire que
académiquement il a pris du retard
[Musique]
et bon on a vu des exemples de joueurs
qui avaient pris du retard Academy et
qu'on réussit mais plus souvent de
l'inverse
donc voilà mais ouais Brandon Miller
je sais pas c'est pas mon préféré des
ailiers qu'on a vu mais
effectivement il a un beau physique
par contre il faut qu'il domine tu vois
si on lui donne la balle comme disait
Thomas faut qu'il fasse tomber tu vois
faut qu'il shoute 6 7 lancé francs par
match faut qu'il faut qu'il aille faut
qu'il aille mettre les pieds dans la
dans la raquette il faut qu'il faut
qu'il soit efficace ça va pas être
facile mais on peut y croire vu le style
de jeu j'ai vu le contexte aussi le
coach il y a quand même des ingrédients
qui peuvent plaider en sa faveur sachant
qu'en plus le foot c'est quand même
aussi c'est travaillable je veux dire
[Musique]
mais en plus il a il a pas un toucher
nul tu vois bon marché donc ça veut dire
que il y a une base correcte
Thomas merci on va passer à la Walker la
carte blanche d'Alex un mineur peut en
cacher un autre du coup on va parler de
Adam Miller de LS you j'ai intitulé
renaître après une année shirt c'est un
peu tout le défi et oui
c'est très bien titre
Adam Miller pour ceux qui avaient
regardé la finale du Shiba U19
de timide USF à la France
de la France de Victor one byama il
fallait le citer on est obligé de le
citer une fois par émission
[Musique]
il était là il était même titulaire si
j'ai pas de bêtises
ou alors il était sixième homme mais il
était là grosse intensité défensive
qu'il a apporté ensuite à Illinois où il
a transféré et puis après il s'est
blessé il a pas joué l'année dernière et
elle est issue l'année dernière c'est
complètement casser la gueule avec et
bien
à Pierre tu vas pas me croire mais leur
coach
a été suspendu parce qu'il aurait
contrevenu aux règles de recrutement
c'est à dire qu'il aurait donné de la tu
vas pas me croire qu'il aurait donné
une histoire de promesses d'argent le
fameux
exactement
vous venez visiter notre fac mais vous
savez que vous avez gagné un sac de
sport oui les lourdes oui oui les lourds
donc voilà le coach s'est fait virer
tous les prospects sont partis et donc
le nouveau coach le pauvre a dû
McMahon a dû faire avec avec les moyens
du bord il a fait une équipe à peu près
correcte mais Adam Miller aura de
grosses responsabilités je pense au
scoring
et
ben il va falloir qu'il roule sur des
gens parce que il est vieux enfin il est
vieux il a 21 années il était déjà pas
si jeune que ça quand il était freshman
il aura 21 ans à la draft donc voilà je
on veut voir on veut voir du volume à
trois points et de la réussite il est à
34% en fraîcheman en réussite
pas fou mais c'est pas nul mais voilà il
a il a un très beau tir il est bien
compact etc et puis c'est un joueur
d'énergie quoi donc
je ne désespère pas de voir Adam Miller
devenir une sorte de super défenseur
avec avec du punch offensif et capable
de voilà de
d'aller provoquer un nombre de lancés
francs incalculable et de vraiment
dominer physiquement même en SEP
donc je pense qu'il aura les
opportunités pour le faire
MacMahon en plus à coach pas si mal
c'était le coach de murs et state pour
les fans de diamant
donc donc c'est pas mal ça joue bien
enfin ça joue un basket propre mais ces
dernières années c'était pas désagréable
à jouer ça va nous changer de LSU qui
était quand même un beau bordel pour
être gentil
donc
voilà il y aura il y aura il y a du
boulot il y aura aucune qui est mistri
dans l'équipe parce que voilà c'est une
équipe montée au mois de avril pour
novembre pour la NCS ça n'a aucun sens
dans une équipe de coach en plus donc
donc voilà il a pas un contexte
favorable mais justement s'il fait une
bonne saison là dedans ça veut dire que
il y a un beau joueur qui se cache
derrière
et ce que on imagine pas un petit peu
dans un rôle d'un autre joueur de SSI
l'année dernière un peu
la checker Ford qui faisait feu de tout
bois l'année dernière à la Baba est-ce
qu'on n'est pas un peu dans ce registre
là avec Adam humeur
sans avoir la balle
ouais je pense qu'il a plus de
il a peut-être un peu plus de
punch vers le cercle ouais
[Musique]
quand même moi
ça c'est sympa en tout cas ça a un
joueur comprend plaisir à voir c'est
vrai c'est genre de voir qui marque et
qu'on aime bien voir même si
je trouve que ça avoir très très sympa
j'aime bien puis j'aime bien le maillot
de LS you et ça va me faire plaisir de
voir jouer à des Sioux donc je suis
content
messieurs
on en est à 1h34 donc c'est très bien on
va bientôt s'arrêter ce que vous avez
des choses à rajouter que vous avez
oublié vous dites azulte ça je l'ai pas
dit Thomas je pense qu'on est bon on a
je peux dire qu'on a cité que la
personnellement j'ai cité que si
prospects mais il y en a évidemment
plein d'autres à regarder en ici
beaucoup donc je sais que c'était une
contrainte pour toi ça a été choisir
mais beaucoup de gens à regarder ouais
dans tout le pays comme dans cette
conférence donc ça va être vraiment
vraiment forte appréciable cette année
j'ai l'impression il y a le il y a les
articles de Thomas sur le site pour ceux
qui veulent par position alors il y a
que les freshman mais Hugues va
s'occuper des des uppers classman donc
donc ça fait déjà je sais pas il y en a
au moins 6 7 par position donc ça fait
une trentaine de joueurs à regarder à
observer il y a une très belle cuvée la
longueur cette année c'est ça Mathias
est contentant
ouais est-ce que tu as des choses à
rajouter que tu as
omis tout à l'heure et où je t'ai coupé
la parole qu'elle a mal aux crues dis
moi non non
regardez la vitesse même s'il y a pas de
recrues 5 étoiles top niveau me laisser
pas seul
le cri du coeur
messieurs merci beaucoup bravo à vous
pour votre première c'était très très
bien
boss comme d'habitude
merci à toi on va remercier Baptiste
pour le visuel sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est lui qui nous l'a fait Maxime et
Louis pour la com une pensée à eux qu'il
devait être là et qui malheureusement a
sa famille qui est co donc on pense fort
à lui faites attention d'ailleurs le
covid revient c'est l'infirmier qui vous
parle à coucou
on fait la bise à tous les autres parce
que maintenant on a une grande équipe
donc on va pas tous les citer mais on
oublie personne n'oubliez pas de nous
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux on va
investir beaucoup plus Instagram cette
année aussi Twitter évidemment parce que
c'est la base abonnez-vous sur Youtube
vous activez évidemment la cloche vous
prenez soin de vous et puis nous on va
se donner rendez-vous très vite sans
doute vers 21h ça leur elle va pas trop
changer la date je sais pas encore mais
on vous tient au courant à très bientôt
bye bye
salut à tous